How do I find out if I'm TH-1 or TH-2-dominated, do I need to get tested by who, where do I go?
So first of all, you have to find out if you have an autoimmune disease or what stage
of that autoimmune disease you are, there's three stages of autoimmune disease.
But in order to find out if you have antibodies to self-tissue, you really have to go to do a
Syrex test again.
The Syrex is a lab, so that's the name of a lab, and they are specialists in running antibody
testing.
So Syrex Labs is what labs that you would get in the order room through our site or any
functional medicine doctor that knows anything would be running Syrex Labs.
This particular one that I show with diagrams up here is the Syrex array 14, which is the
Mucosol immune reaction test, a test, a bunch of antibodies for different tissues and different
things in your body, just to give a general picture overview.
There's this person having autoimmune disease.
You could certainly run a standard lab core test and test for different antibodies, but
like A&A, antibodies, and there's different things that you could test for lab core through
your doctor as well.
So you want to see if you have antibodies to self-tissue, thyroid test, CFM antibodies to
the thyroid, TPO, antibodies, things like that.
How do you know if your TH-1 or TH-2 dominant, where you can vary between TH-1 or TH-2 dominant
dominant, and the best way to really know that is just clinically.
So there's not really a test for that.
I mean, you can run cytokine panels, but those can change day to day too, so that really
wouldn't be the perfect test for that.
So in a TH-1 dominant, your body is releasing a greater amount of different types of chemicals
called cytokines than you are the TH-2 dominant.
One of the best ways to do that is just from a clinical standpoint is if you are autoimmune
and you take immune supplements, does that make you feel better or worse?
Many of those people, because they're TH-1 dominant, TH-1 side of the immune system is the immune
killer side, TH-2 side is more the B cell, make your antibody side.
So if you're already TH-1 dominant and you do things to stimulate your immune process,
then you'll actually feel worse.
So if I take vitamin C, does it make me feel worse?
Yeah, it really does.
Well, then you're probably TH-1 dominant.
You really should not be taking supplements that are immune stimulants, and if you can find
a list of those in my bulk health, my body's killing me.
If you're TH-2 dominant, same thing.
So you just do taking green T-extract and curcumin, boy, that makes me feel a lot worse, and
I feel better when I take vitamin C, that you're probably TH-2 dominant.
You shouldn't be taking things that stimulate the TH-2 side.
Here's a really a test for that, but you should be testing for antibodies, and if you have
an autoimmune disease, that's what you should be looking for.